la tabla siguiente muestra las
instalaciones de paneles solares por
estado durante el último año fiscal y
nos preguntan cuántos paneles solares
fueron instalados en alabama en el
cuarto trimestre
entonces aquí tenemos nuestra tabla y
alabama está aquí y si vamos al cuarto
trimestre
dice que hay 36 paneles solares a ver
respondamos
muy bien vamos a la siguiente pregunta
y esta también es de paneles solares
ahora nos preguntan cuántos paneles
solares fueron instalados en nueva york
en el segundo trimestre y buscamos en
nuestra tabla a nueva york aquí está el
segundo trimestre es este y observamos
que hay 27
respondemos y eso vamos muy bien
continuemos
ahora dice que la tabla siguiente indica
el número de puntos anotados por cuatro
jugadores está muy bien este de
baloncesto entonces cuántos puntos anotó
kevin en el tercer cuarto
aquí tenemos en nuestros jugadores
tenemos los cuartos de los partidos pero
kevin kevin es este que está aquí el
tercer cuarto pues es esta columna aquí
estamos y fueron nueve puntos
respondemos
eso vamos muy bien la siguiente pregunta
en la siguiente pregunta se refiere a la
inscripción en cuatro escuelas primarias
diferentes que tienen estudiantes de
tercero a quinto grado
cuántos estudiantes tiene la escuela
primaria al mont en total a esta
pregunta es interesante entonces vamos a
observar nuestra tabla aquí está la
escuela al mont y nos preguntan cuántos
tienen total
observamos que el total de
no respondemos
y bien vamos muy bien vamos a la
siguiente pregunta
ahora la tabla siguiente muestra las
instalaciones a través paneles solares
por estado durante el último año fiscal
nos preguntan cuántos paneles solares
fueron instalados en wyoming en el
segundo trimestre aquí están los estados
los trimestres y en el segundo trimestre
vamos a buscar el renglón de wyoming que
es este que está aquí dice que hay 27
muy bien y respondemos eso vamos muy
bien yo creo que con esto ya terminamos
a ver vamos a reciente pregunta claro
muy bien hemos avanzado